Fox News continues to try to thread this
needle where they want to do what they
can to make someone other than Trump the
Republican nominee in 2024 but Fox
doesn't want to go off the deep end off
the diving board so to speak in case
Trump ends up being the nominee so some
of the things Fox News has done to
subtly and softly push voters and public
opinion towards Rhonda Sanders include
they'll do a man on the street segment
and it just so happens that 10 of the 11
people they talk to say I would rather
DeSantis be the nominee than Trump now
of course you can talk to as many people
as you need to until you get enough to
create the narrative that you want and
the narrative that fox chose to create
was let's make these men on the street
segments overwhelmingly point to
Republican voters who prefer DeSantis
over Trump uh they have been giving more
sort of serious positive coverage or at
least neutral coverage to DeSantis
events than they have to Trump events
okay the latest thing is that they are
straight up running like a Ron DeSantis
propaganda special here's the promo for
it take a look
Fox Nations hit doctor series is back
who is Ron DeSantis we will never ever
surrender to the woke mob
he was in the Middle East advising Seal
Team One to advise them you have to be
the best of the best he's a good man
he's a good husband he's a good father
is this Ron desantis's opportunity to
run for higher office I think it is who
is Rhonda Santos streaming now only on
Fox Nation yeah so anyway remember what
Angelo caruson told us about this Fox
News primarily wants to be adjacent to
power and because it's not yet clear
that Donald Trump isn't going to be the
nominee Fox News needs to continue at
least plausibly setting themselves up to
fully jump back on on the Trump train if
Trump is indeed the nominee and if there
are potentially going to be another four
years of a trump Administration however
Rupert Murdoch doesn't think much of
trump and is very clear from the
released text messages that we got last
week that many of the Fox News hosts
don't really think much of trump at
least as far as his level of honesty
this includes Laura Ingram Sean Hannity
Tucker Etc who knew Trump was lying all
along about the big lie and and the
entire thing so so as Angelo told us
when I interviewed him Angelo carry
Stone from Media Matters Fox News wants
to do what it can to push voters to Ron
DeSantis or to anybody so that Trump is
less likely to be the nominee but
they need to have a sort of eject button
right they need to have a an escape pod
to get back to Trump and not completely
sever that relationship because Trump is
such a sycophant and he loves uh because
Trump is such a sycophant lover and he
loves suckups
even though Trump is now criticizing Fox
News as being the Rhino Network and all
of this different stuff if he is the
nominee and if fox goes right back to
him and you know is eating out of his
hand and whatever Trump will go right
back to doing the prime time Fox News
interviews and the entire thing because
Trump loves the attention as well it's a
sort of symbiosis of narcissism and
um a symbiosis of narcissism and uh an
obsession with power that is going to
keep that relationship going if indeed
Trump is the nominee but for the time
being subtly but increasingly less
subtly Fox News is doing what it can
to hope that and and influence the
Republican primary towards someone other
than Trump right now based on the
polling the best Contender of course
would be Ron DeSantis and speaking of
that polling uh we we've got a few
recent polls there is a co-efficient
poll which has DeSantis uh up 33 over
Larry Hogan and Trump up 27 over Larry
Hogan so so like the Santa's performing
slightly better than Trump against Hogan
but DeSantis versus Trump DeSantis is
leading by four however in a multi-way
race if you do Trump DeSantis Hogan
Nikki Haley Mike Pence Mike Pompeo Tim
Scott that's better for Trump and that
is the trend in every single one of
these polls when the polls include more
than just Trump versus DeSantis Trump
tends to lead when the polls are just
Trump versus DeSantis it's much better
for DeSantis in general so that can
continues to be a trend that of course
we are going to follow
imagine for a second that you try
logging into your email account only to
find that your password was changed an
hour ago and then you get notifications
of activity from your bank and then your
credit cards that is what identity theft
is like and it's a horrible feeling and
we dealt with it at the show not that
long ago but now I have an app called
Aura which gives me much more peace of
mind our sponsor Aura is the all-in-one
solution for keeping your online account
safe because Aura will scan the dark web
for your personal info passwords social
security number and you get fast alerts
when they find something you also get
fast alerts about credit inquiries Aura
protects all of your devices from
malware or even requests the removal of
your info from data broker sites and
Aura helps you manage what your kids can
do on their devices you can restrict
certain apps set screen time limits set
Focus times when you need them off of
devices is go to aura.com Pacman to try
it free for seven days your login
credentials might already be floating
around out there and Aura will tell you
instantly for free the link is down
below